hey guys i'm ryan right I'm Andrew so I
rot Andrew here today with me to do a
spoiler talk of the series premiere of
fear of the walking dead I mean from
critics it's been getting pretty solid
feedback from audiences I'm noticing
it's a little bit more divided you know
so and I feel like what makes this show
really work is the details of everything
so that's why I wanted to do it it's
like why do a spoiler talk over a series
from here but I'm like now there's
actually things worth exploring in this
first episode and I brought andrew here
with me today because he hasn't actually
been watching the walking dead the
original series and I thought I'd be
cool if I brought someone on who was
watching a prequel show for the first
time without having seen the original
and I've seen the original so I thought
be a cool little talk to see both point
of view Ryan has been trying to get me
on this bandwagon and I definitely watch
the last night and I've never seen
walking dead and not cool like everyone
else and I felt the characters were
really good i thought the dialogue was
really good and i thought the story was
pretty easy to fall I didn't think it
was convoluted or too confusing like
what the hell they're trying to be beef
to fancy it was very easy to follow and
the main thing is I cared about what
happened to the characters I didn't want
anything to happen to them that's what
made each scene intense yeah like the
opening scene was interesting to me
because it starts off in a church which
is already like oh wow this is not
pretty it's a church I knew it was a
prequel going in but I can I can only
imagine for someone who didn't know is a
prequel like dude what are you doing
that's clearly a zombie you know it's a
traumatizing event for this guy who you
could tell as a junkie it's his own
girlfriend you know so it automatic
automatically makes this whole zombie
things start off personal and what I
think a lot of people aren't realizing
is a lot of drama occurs but it's all
because of that opening scene of why all
the dramas starting to really go down
and my favorite part of that opening say
my favorite part it really establishes
this is going to be different it's going
to be a different world when he goes on
to the street gets hit by a car and then
the camera people are swarming them and
and they do it as if like are those
zombies it pans up and you're like oh
[ __ ] is just la in water day then
love like you just said I'm just gonna
add to exactly just said i love how they
did that word you can see like you think
it's an apocalypse there's nobody around
and then Oh sudden people are coming
then it's modern Dale I was like oh wow
that was a neat little trick I like that
a guy play Nick I don't know his name
but his character it was interesting cuz
when he first started off like they're
in the hospital dysfunctional family i'm
like okay i get the art types of all
these characters I go they're all
supposed to be but as the show
progressed it got better and better and
the characters became better I really
like Cliff Curtis oh yeah and I loved
the relationship he forms a nikka what
it had a little bit of psychology to it
you know it was like he really cares
about Nick but also he's trying to make
up for his other son that doesn't want
to have a relationship with them yeah
and I'm interested in seeing more that
actually know that actor Lorenzo Henry
James Henry it's a good-looking lad as
you watch your videos sometimes oh
please watch in this point you're you're
good dude mm-hmm you need more scenes
for the second episode telling you and
so those are the producers like as you
said like that first he's it just seems
like he's your typical junkie hey I want
attention everyone you know pay
attention to me kind of thing but then
as each scene you know guide more
particular i just i really felt like I
cared for this guy and also you could
see the [ __ ] in his eyes from what is
the the fur from the first scene of his
girlfriend what she did you know like
through this fool is scared out of his
mind needs to find out what the heck is
going on yeah that was really great it
was an interesting journey of a heroin
addict because you're like definitely
cuz you could see how people would think
he was totally hallucinating right
absolutely I do like that relationship
that forms with him and Cliff Curtis and
some people are debatable about like
should cook courtesy should just told
the police what he said I was like if he
told the police everything there would
be a whole murder investigation open and
all this other crap he wanted to help
him and find out if he was hallucinating
or not you know absolutely he was just
being a good father yeah I just doing
what any good father would have done you
know I mean I guess that's debatable
because I'm in someone's would some
people would argue oh he should have
went to the cops but you want to make
sure that he wasn't hallucinating like
you just said Norton that or if he was
crazy said there's nothing there I want
their you know so I I thought that was
very they made the character smart you
know they made a character smart and the
cool teases throughout of what's going
to get bigger because if you ever
watched if you ever decide to watch The
Walking Dead like from first season to
the end of it there's always a build-up
at each season tells us some specific
story by the final episode it's the most
intense episode of the season so I feel
like they're doing that really well with
the first episode and I feel like people
are like disappointed with it I'm like
it's the first episode one scene I
really did like was that kid who got
caught with a knife yeah and then he was
in the I think Kim Dickens man yeah yeah
Kim Dickens and when he was talking with
her there's an interesting world going
on here where you're like because I know
of The Walking Dead I know of the
apocalypse now that they're having this
conversation it's like man I totally get
why she thinks his kids just stupid but
I really wish you would listen to him
you know it does a really good job
instead of making you go what a bunch of
idiots it makes you go I get why they're
not acknowledging the gravity of the
situation you know I agree and also
again just adding to just you know the
great characters also you could see on
that kids eyes and that when he's being
when she's talking to him about having
the knife he's scared of his leg like he
just wants that for protection yeah I
mean yeah that's what I mean and a big
theme of the walking dead and this show
which I like is because they're both
about survival yes but it's a different
kind of survival story like there's this
great scene when Curtis yeah when cliff
Curtis is giving a speech right logo so
Jack London book I was so engraved in
the story i could not a wolf yeah it was
a good story of but having a cliff
Curtis talk about like man versus nature
survival instincts before the apocalypse
is going to happen it's interesting
because you're like you do see how
people don't become aware of who they
can become in certain situations you
know right how you can become like the
whole idea of like eating someone else
or some [ __ ] like Lord of the Flies yeah
like yeah no absolutely it was it was a
cool foreshadowing moment I thought for
in that in that scene like ya doing
that's a good work yeah absolutely and I
mean a lot of filmmakers like to do that
in their TV shows or movies
no show what's about to happen but
absolutely I thought that was really
cool i love cliff curtis again like we
were talking about he's really
interesting character and scan wait see
where we go from there and then that
seemed worth a guy like int in the
classroom where the kid like comes up
with the full explanation of man versus
nature and they's like good job that was
a good explanation right there yeah okay
this is good right as like I like that
like good character I like how they were
having fun and you know you were saying
you're excited for what's to come and I
feel like they gave teases as what's to
come you see that moment where the
principal the black guy might be uh yeah
yeah really like he might be a song in
and they reveal you're like ah he wasn't
a zombie because the walking dead never
really does a human sense of humor like
that yeah and then at one point they're
doing a shop where they're driving in
the car looks like there might be a
zombie in the part you see missing child
signs when Nick is in the hospital and
the old man's dying you're like yeah
because okay yeah like it knows how to
do all these great little hints and and
make you think about stuff so builds
fearing yeah absolutely like you just
said i love how they don't hit you over
the head and like fully say it right
then there you actually have to think
about it just that that thought of it
the fear of it like you said it's just
intense and like again because of how
good the characters are you don't want
anything to happen like no don't turned
is I'm here don't get killed you know so
yeah it's good ready just hoping they
survive when the apocalypse out that's
exactly what I really love that I
thought they that you cannot do with the
walking dead was the reveal of that
freeway chase scene where they were
shooting the guy and he wouldn't go down
and how everyone was like on you to the
new social media looking at this and
having like fear instilled and then the
print like it was scary because the
first half of that episode is just
character just character and then slowly
the internet starts releasing this
footage suddenly the school's like
you're getting a half day that on the
freeway just having it like a normal
talk and then bad in the boat and also
remember to and the principal comes into
the bus he's like five kids would you
forget a bunch of stops and when they
introduce Calvin yes I was like yeah
just a nice little nice young black
blood I like him he's cool guy people
are gonna be like what
at the point he was black I don't know I
just said it he was a cool introduction
to him you're like okay I get his
character and then they flip it and
you're like okay he's the heroin dealer
he's the one providing the drugs and
stuff and but that scene in the diner
one like this guy's just trying to
figure out is this guy it was Nick
snitching on me and nick is like I just
need to know what the would [ __ ] I took
you know is one of why I'm seeing the
agents of my girlfriend like this I love
how is it kind of reminded me of like
when you see a performance like DiCaprio
in like shutter island or something
where someone's paranoia is just
consuming them more and more and more so
that seemed when he's like breaking down
he finally feels like you found peace
but he sees that Calvin's about to pull
a gun on him that goes back to the
foreshadowing of the survival instincts
you know you're seeing the ugliness of
man before the zombie apocalypse happens
it's not like a cool action scene it's
like this is kind of violent and this is
a friend of his that he just killed I
know you wanted to talk about the
daughter's boyfriend hmm Matt yeah Matt
I just I thought that I liked I really
actually felt the chemistry between the
two actors you know I actually enjoyed
their scenes together i bided I thought
they were actually you know they had a
connection between the two and I was
very interested to see what was going on
with him because she had text him for a
couple days I guess and he was they were
supposed to meet at the beach I guess
first and then after that you know no
she didn't come to school because like
half the school didn't anyway so and
then he wasn't even responding or so I'm
very curious to see what's going what
what exactly has happened to him because
has he turned into a zombie what or
what's more towards he just lost his
cell phone you know what's going on you
know so I'm very curious to see where it
happens with that he's probably a zombie
black zombie meaning it's a zombie with
a huge dick beware that's how he infects
the last moments of that show where
they're going to find Nick and nicks and
they find Nick and then dicks like I
killed Galvan I'd like to it's like
smoking astir yeah damn this full really
killed someone like you can tell ya it's
not like he just killed someone is like
we're like he's traumatized by the fact
that he killed like his world is just
crumbling apart enough best friend to
yeah and then when they go to see him
it's like it was a good zombie seen it
was a really good zombie build up seeing
they're taking it as if what if no one
has seen the walking dead and they're
only watching this show it's this thing
they experience on the news where
there's this guy he's clearly infected
with something and he won't go down so
they run him over with a car they run
him over with a car okay you know like
the age is still [ __ ] movie yeah and
it's intense because you're like we know
what's gonna come but these characters
that we really care about don't know
what's gonna come you know and now that
has officially been confirmed for them
when they see that their best friend who
they've been trying to run over for the
last five minutes is still walking and
trying to kill them so yeah I mean yeah
I know when again just looking at the
panic you know I know I keep saying this
over and over but if you look at the
panic in the actors you know eyes in
their face you can tell like they're
very scared and you can tell what's
about to happen at they've come to the
realization this is actually real this
is gonna happen it's a nightmarish
experience because we know what's gonna
come but people that we love because it
was cool because these characters start
off like ok these are pretty
stereotypical but then as it progresses
and the details of them you're like
they're not so stereotypical there's
actually depth to them so when you get
to that moment you know that feeling um
kind of know why this is the first one
that comes to mind but you know how an
episode 3 you're kind of like I don't
want Anakin to turning to Darth Vader
yeah or um DC Moulin Rouge I saw the
ending well in the beginning of the
movie they say she dies okay it's right
at the beginning I'm not rude Anton
breda they say that the very beginning
she's dead uh-huh but I was watching
that movie I was like I don't you know
but you know she's it's one of those
feelings like you can't do anything
about it it's not like that tank I don't
want this ship to sink you know if ya
happens are it's good it's too late it's
too late they showed you on the trailers
20 years ago um boil alert the ship goes
down ship my toes sorry yeah nobody I
spoiled that damn I bet then James
Cameron found it but yeah guys thanks
for tuning in hearing us talk about the
sport hopefully you guys caught the
episode I've liked hearing what you guys
are also saying i have been reading the
comments so thank you guys for sharing
your feedback if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can check out andrew on
twitter twitter.com slash Igor
7 11 okay you said that with the seven
below its good i am Jack Donaghy you can
follow the real rejects on Facebook
Instagram Twitter my periscope because
if we didn't have followers we can get
even more product placement for things
such as pins see pins are great you know
if you're ever needing to stick
something on the wall a pin if you ever
have to you know hurt a friend a pin
they won't even know you know like my
friends constantly pissed me off I don't
even like most of my friends I just keep
their hands I'm a little codependent but
makes sense yeah it's like I need
friends so I could count them but i
don't really like them but every once in
a while i'll keep a pin on my hand shake
their hand oh bam they get said I go to
what the [ __ ] just at me like I don't
know bee stung you man get that bee
stinger ouch yeah I'll make sure I just
just pumped you from knowing how you can
fix me whenever you want pins